good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday it is the
first Monday in May which is Iconic for
so many reasons but the most important
reason it's important today is because
altivia ashrae is here our big sis
Olivia is joining me today because
Claudia is off gallivanting in Palm
Springs at stagecoach with our other
sister it's just like kind of War of the
sisters but live trout skin how are you
thank you for joining us hi Angel well
thank you so much for having me I have
like so many things to say right off the
bat because one you said the morning
toast which I feel like actually oh my
gosh but it's perfect for me because I
legitimately have not been on this show
in like
I I obviously have I haven't been on the
show since it's been called the toast
but it's been years so like it feels
like the throwback is almost like
semi-intentional for me and I so
appreciate that it's not I did it on
Thursday too and Claudia called me out
and I guess typically she does the intro
after getting morning Millennials so
like I haven't had to correct myself to
it took her like weeks to stop saying
morning and I just didn't even think
about it welcome back to the toast in
the morning of course but not the
morning toes damn the one and only yeah
and also first Monday in May first of
all like how the [__] is it may like
that's really alarming to me like we're
halfway through the year I feel like
legitimately it was just New Year's like
am I the only person that feels that way
it's like bizarre things are really like
going so fast but the days feel so
[__] long but I'm also shook it
that like we are almost really halfway
through the air yeah but we're not
halfway through the year until the end
of June correct
correct but like we're so we're
basically there
okay sure like we're in month five of
the Year already it's just I don't know
it's blowing my mind it's blowing my
mind it's crazy well everyone's gonna be
so excited that you are joining me today
because as we said you haven't been on
the toast in so long probably years I
can't even remember the last time
definitely not since you've moved to
Florida so for everyone listening can we
get like a little live catch up like
what's new with you how are you what's
Liv up to what's Liv up to I'm good I'm
just living my best life here in Florida
you know I think also you and I were
talking about this not that long ago but
the reason why the world feels like it's
moving so fast is because Levi is
already six months and I'm like not
mentally prepared to be having like a
six month old and then Kay's birthday is
in May she's turning three so wow that's
what's up with me it's just like time is
flying I know people say like it goes so
fast cherish it and I always like kind
of roll my eyes when I hear that because
it's like annoying but it's so true it's
like really to pressing and happy all at
the same time I know I feel like I get
so many targeted videos on reels and all
of them are about like parenting and
kids and they're so nice but there are
so many that are just all about like how
the time goes so quickly and you know
it's like they have that new trend where
they play that song and it's like the
kid is Young and then it switches songs
and the kid is like older and it's so
nice but like it's really kind of like
[__] depressing and can't we just
like enjoy and not just like talk about
how quickly it's going and how quickly
it's going to go yeah there's this new
um Tick Tock slash reel going around
I've seen it like three times in the
last 24 hours and it's like you only
have like 15 Spring Breaks two different
proms one first date like cherish it all
and it's like it's weeny but it's also
true like no do you know what I mean
okay I understand that it's true but
it's like stop counting like stop
counting just live it's oh that really
like stresses me out and I find it to be
someone necessary yeah Live and Let Live
you know that should be the name of this
podcast episode okay I will consider it
if nothing better comes up and if I find
that that is like a constant theme of
the episode that we are living and
letting live absolutely YOLO is another
one I could present you only live once
you know if you just want to be able
theme yeah yeah I don't know okay we'll
see you let me know we'll see where the
episode so takes us but I'm not opposed
I'm not opposed thank you for being so
open-minded I really appreciate that
about you
oh my God that's so sweet thanks you
actually are one of the most open-minded
people I've ever met you know like you
just you're a pleasure to have a
conversation with
oh my God this is just compliment hour
is it we never like talked we never
since we never podcast together we never
have to like talk to each other like
podcasters we can just like you know
totally [__] and I feel like actually
like the last time I did the toast the
morning toast it was with Claudia like I
don't know when I've ever done an
episode even just with you we do a lot
of patreon episodes yeah we do a lot of
patrons and also when we were both
Brides like I remember you came on a lot
when Claudia was on the dirty jeans tour
um that was really when we were vibing
um
same and we're gonna get into all the
stories today I'm gonna put you to work
you know typical toast but before we do
I think you and I like need to talk
about our sisters
um a snatchler and snatchler too yeah in
Palm Springs have you been following I
mean how could you not be following
their weekend Claudia and Margo are at
Stagecoach uh and they just look
insanely sickening sickening sickness
it's a pleasure to watch them it is a
pleasure and I feel like I
as you know just kind of this Suburban
Mom I'm living vicariously through them
like every time I see Claudia or Margo
or Shannon like somebody come up on my
Instagram where there's like new content
it's like I legitimately and probably
the first person to click because you're
the second because I'm the first no I
re-watch it I'm like so enthralled by it
and like I would say this to Margot
openly like when she posts from a
concert like I'll be the first to tap
through because like I don't find it
appealing but this is a whole other
level like I I hope that they save all
their stories they could turn it into a
documentary and I would watch it every
night before I go to sleep
your way
your way like no but you know
any content that I hope Never Dies
because continue to resurface I'm
sitting at home and I'm it's like seven
o'clock I'm like okay well it's four
o'clock in California maybe they're
dressed for the day and they posted
their outfits totally invested did you
have you spoken to your sisters like are
they having a good time I'm like I don't
[__] need to speak to them they're
having the time of their lives yeah no
and you know Claudia is Gonna Come on
the toes tomorrow and spill all and tell
us every detail and I'm really excited
to hear I did talk to her today and they
are confirmed having a good time but I
do get the sense because it's the truth
that like having a good time is
exhausting oh absolutely in 100 degree
heat like how could you
you know there's there's that always
like one percent of trash that and plus
it being in a festival right like the
thing about a festival is like you're
going to the bathroom in a porta potty
you're waiting online for a drink you're
being shoved in the mosh pit of a crowd
like there's just certain things about a
festival that are just Festival life but
it looks just Primo demo WeMo you know
yeah no I'm definitely a proud big sis
living vicariously through what's been
your favorite outfit of theirs oh I just
literally saw Claudia's outfit for today
and she was wearing like this kind of
like checkerboard pattern like sweater
vesty sort of thing set and I was like
damn girl like she was looking straight
fire flames and then Margo's blue outfit
yesterday I think like crushed so those
I would say I think are my top two right
now but like I don't know honestly the
denim skirt on Claudia like so not
prepared for that moment and it is uh
etched in my memory forever
yeah um um I I love Claudia's Day 2
outfit the green dress the green dress
of course and Marco's day two outfit the
blue outfit like obsessed she like made
a little Tick Tock video I was like it
just like wasn't long enough and you
were standing too far away from the
camera like we didn't get to see enough
I'm like referring to every story I'm
like show it from this angle like when
she took a picture and like sent it to
the steens like when they were first
dressed I like it was jarring I'm like
whoa my phone is gonna blow up from it's
overheating you know yeah it was it was
too hot to handle too hot to handle
that's for sure well I'm so excited for
the episode to hear all the things
um you know because I am admittedly like
a selective toast listener because
I feel like I talk to you guys every
second of every day that I like I know
your take on everything I know what you
do with your lives so thus I don't
necessarily have to expend the hour plus
a day because I'm living it
um nor do I always have the hour pasta
diet you know so that will be an episode
into
yeah that will be good and do you listen
like when you hear that we've talked
about you a hundred percent because like
people were texting me like I heard
about you on the toes today you're this
you're that or haha about Shapiro and
I'm like aha what so then I have to go
tune in until like does that does that
scare you or it's it's fun no I I know
that you guys unless you're like [__]
making [__] up about me would you do
something else do you know yeah no
there's a few stories in our Arsenal
that we disagree on the art the history
of yeah no I think it's actually more
fun for people who I get a lot of text
like I'm a toaster now or my so and so
was talking about the toast and they
can't believe I know you and then it's
like oh well here I am today you know
I'm on the toes too so that would be fun
I think yeah
so you don't want me to tell the story
about The Backstreet Boys I mean you
could tell it but it's actually
inaccurate it's all like it's fine and
by the way like people who have been
listening to the show for years they
know the [__] story because we've
talked about it no I don't think we've
ever
Ed worry because it's
it's oh definitely on patreon and you're
right because it's that much of a hot
button issue between us yeah because you
guys are in a cabal against me like to
make like try to rewrite history and
pretend that I have these memories and I
don't know but like it's not that it's
not no everyone says I have such a good
memory and this is one of my youngest
memories my earliest memories and most
cherished sure but we won't get into it
it's just like a little squabble about
like Olivia's love for the Backstreet
Boys because I wasn't it I know the
number one in sync girl admittedly I
wanted like my body JC Jose okay we know
we know that I don't know but before you
got into in sync like before you
discovered them and like fell head over
heels there was a brief period where you
did like the Backstreet Boys just
because it was like the thing to like
and your Backstreet Boy of choice was
Brian
um by the way confirmer today confirm
obviously but in today's day and age
like good for me because the rest of
them I don't know yeah you know yeah
yeah I do agree I obviously have good
taste in men I guess yeah I'm a young
age to be Scandal free Scandal free yeah
yeah yeah yeah JC chose a also Scandal
free from what I can from what I know
haven't really I didn't have a Google
alert on him or anything yeah
sure just Brian
stop
with you
okay well I'm so glad that you're here
to join us for the past five today we
have some great stories and I want to
get Liv's Take On Pop Culture because
you dabble and I feel like there are
subjects that you that you really care
about you don't care about some of the
things that like Claude And I do but the
things that you're passionate about like
you are a forensic investigator and 100
you know more than anyone about your
passion subjects a hundred percent no
other way to be no other way to be what
would you say are your passion subjects
for those who don't know
influencer drama influencer drama for
sure but like not the kind of influencer
drama that most people care about yeah
not like not like these teeny boppers no
mine is like I don't know food blogger
sort of stuff you know like I'm just in
a totally different space
um no my MO is that I'd like to know a
little bit about everything like I I
just like to be a well-rounded person
you know I just I don't really like read
like you know I don't like read news and
entertainment news and I'm not like live
and die by certain things but
um you know I just like to be able to be
conversational about any sort of
mainstream topic that's going to come up
so I don't really watch reality TV I
used to a lot but I don't anymore but
again like know all the players know the
situation just not spending hours of my
week watching it because like one I
don't have the time and two I feel like
you can find out a good amount of
information about what's going on just
by being alive in the world
yeah and you and Shapiro like your weird
shows I love I just like shows that have
you know a plot
you like some actions
and like a government body yeah no like
cop dramas like it's totally my vibe
government care literacy yeah you name
it The Blacklist The Blacklist love it
night agent I just finished it was
incredible and but here's the thing I'm
watching Firefly Lane and it's
unbelievable and oh you like it oh I
love it I just think it's like it's so
drama-filled you know I like the drama I
read the book
I heard it's nothing like the book you
know I didn't read the book but I know
the book made me angry and then I was
like I'm not watching the show oh
interesting oh I feel like if maybe I
read the book I might have the same
experience but you know that's what I'll
be up to tonight
um I will be watching Firefly Lane and I
watch the one reality show that I watch
is Love is Blind Shapiro and I cannot
get enough of it I don't know why you
thought okay great that's a great
pop culture touch Point what were your
thoughts on the reunion that everyone's
talking about the reunion was horrendous
it was just you think that Vanessa and
Nick should be replaced like the
petition says I don't I mean I saw
somewhere that they're like executive
producers on the show so I don't
necessarily know that they're going to
be replaced but like I just don't like
when you are the host of something where
you like have such an obvious agenda and
on some of the points you're like really
wrong like I think that's where Andy
Cohen does a really good job because he
comes into those reunions and he doesn't
necessarily have an agenda obviously
there's things that he wants to get
answered on behalf of the audience but
like that's not really what Vanessa was
doing she just kept like the way that
the whole thing was organized the
conversations that were had the
questions that were asked the things
that she harped on also the way that
they edited it like some things were so
incomplete like consistent no I thought
it was like not live and it was recorded
after because Netflix couldn't figure
out the live no so it was live streamed
if even though they were [__] up and
you like what we watch what Claudia and
I watched was the live cut and then when
they put it on Netflix they did edit it
a little bit I don't know what they
that's what I watch because I watched it
like a week late got it yeah yeah no but
even like the girl Jackie she had like a
pre-recorded like web you know like Zoom
WebEx thing and she was like one of the
worst offenders on the show and the
questions were like hunky dory for her I
don't know it was just not the vibe yeah
but I'm here for Brett and Tiffany they
seem like a great couple
um Bliss and Zach I don't know just I
don't know it was just all sorts of
weird this season I think it's also
because people do go on the show knowing
that like you are gonna get some level
of Fame and then also it's like reality
TV you don't know what kind of edit
you're gonna get
um so it's just all those things mixed
together with this very bizarre
experiment which now things are coming
out about it where they like don't feed
them and don't let them sleep and the
conditions are really bad everyone's
eating and they're always drinking one
person from the season before that guy
Nick who did get married and then got a
divorce is like doing this whole thing
on how like the treatment of
um the folks on the show is no bueno
I'll check it out but there's literally
see this is where I go down deep web on
things that no one cares about
um but here I am
no that's that's useful information
thank you you're welcome you're welcome
okay without further Ado Liv and I are
going to get into the fastest stories
that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
Thrive market so if you've been
listening to the toast or you even watch
my amazing Instagram stories you know
that I love Thrive Market is my go-to
for all of my grocery and household
essentials and the convenience of
getting it all quickly shipped to my
doorstep is a huge Time Saver I go to
thrive market for everything in my
kitchen from food for me snacks for Zach
and I food for Harry snacks for Harry
cleaning supplies like everything clean
in this clean era that I'm in I can get
it on Thrive market and I love that they
do the vetting for you so that all you
have to do is log on to thrive Market
choose which items that you need and you
can have so much Security in the fact
that they are selling clean healthy
products for you not only does thrive
Market save me money but they also save
me time I love the filters on their
website or app they have over 70 filters
so if you're a vegetarian if you're keto
if you're paleo you just let them know
and they will give you all of the
options that are appropriate for you
saves you so much time better than going
through the grocery aisle and looking at
the back of all the ingredients lists
wondering if you can have something when
you join Thrive Market you are also
helping a family in need with their one
for one membership matching program you
join they give join Thrive market today
and get 30 off your first order plus a
free 60 gift go to thrivemarket.com the
toast for 30 off your first order plus a
free 60 gift that's
t-h-r-i-v-e market.com slash the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by Squarespace we love Squarespace here
at the toast because we love that
entrepreneurial spirit and Squarespace
is an amazing platform that allows you
to build your business Squarespace is
everything to sell anything Squarespace
has the tools you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has merchandising features
to make your products look their best
online you can connect with your
audience and generate Revenue through
gated members only content manager
members and email Communications and
leverage audience insights all on one
easy to use platform so Squarespace has
these amazing capabilities that could
take you years to learn but on their
platform it is all there easy to use and
it makes running your own business and
managing your community so so easy we
recommend Squarespace because they have
video blocks you can present your videos
from YouTube or any video creation app
you can connect to social media accounts
you can have other contributor have
access to your site's website manager so
someone can help you in your passion
projects and that is one of the many
reasons why we love Squarespace so head
to squarespace.com toast for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain
again that is squarespace.com toast and
use offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain we
love Squarespace and if you want to
start that passion project that's side
hustle now is the time and Squarespace
is the platform
okay our first story is some sad news
taking off the stories I'm sorry to say
because um at the end of last week it
was announced that Jerry Springer passed
away the legendary TV host was 79 years
old and he was one of the most
influential talk show hosts in TV
history he died peacefully in his home
in suburban Chicago on Thursday his
family confirmed a quartering to a
report from his longtime employer they
said quote Jerry's ability to connect
with people was at the heart of his
success in everything he tried whether
that was politics broadcasting or just
joking with people on the street who
wanted a photo or a word he is
irreplaceable and his loss hurts
immensely but memories of his intellect
heart and humor will live on he was
reportedly diagnosed with cancer a few
months ago which unfortunately took a
bad turn this past week according to TMZ
it's so sad I saw that notification come
in and just like
Jerry Springer like Maury as well were
just such Staples of our childhood like
if you were a kid and you were sick and
home from school you watched Jerry
Springer like your parents had no idea
what you were doing up in your room
while you were supposed to be resting
but you were watching Jerry Springer and
I just feel like it's so iconic for kids
that are now no longer kids but like our
generation
um but it kind of goes back to the
conversation we were having earlier like
he's 79 years old it's terrible that
um you know he passed it's terrible that
he had cancer
um and I just I hope he lived a good
life you know
yeah I think that he did he was a major
Pioneer in television he was there for
all of us yeah when we were sick we were
upstairs being like Jerry Jerry yeah but
then you think about it like the way
that he was so a part of our Lives it
was like more than 20 years ago
20ish years ago you know so it's like
time it was really flying still doing
his show Claudia saw his show like
five six years ago yeah yeah I remember
that
insane yeah oh that's so sad I also in
his passing have learned that he was the
mayor of Cincinnati for a point was he
oh my God that's crazy
yeah crazy that's why it said politics
in that little blurb
oh wow um a multi-talented man
yeah it's just like
there's some people when they pass like
the world is never the same and to be
honest with you today's kids
it's just not the same no they won't
know they won't know they won't know
what it's like but in the same room
where I have the memory of like watching
Jerry Springer is the same room I have
the memory of like that Brian story
which is my childhood room which is your
childhood room that's where we used to
watch Jerry yeah that is where we used
to watch jars beside posters of Brian it
was kind of cool we had a TV in our room
as kids yeah we did but like the quality
was always like so bad that you couldn't
be addicted to it you know what I mean
no yeah it was like really hard to get
up to change the channel so it wasn't
like you were just like laying around
all day watching no for sure no the one
thing that I feel like I know that we
watched like weekly was
um
heaven yeah seventh heaven seventh
heaven and then the OC like when that
first started and that's when we got
Laguna Beach the hills
um you know yeah when we were older and
like more when we like moved to the city
era it was like right at the cost baby
yeah but like growing up we used to
watch the WB every Friday night like
catch us there all the four of us like
watching together you know 100 the WB
was lit it was I remember actually when
they rebranded to the CW that was like
my first experience with a Rebrand and I
was confused
so do you find it to be a successful
Rebrand did it like spur Your Love of
branding or no I don't know actually I
remember in the moment feeling really
angry about it like what the heck is
this yeah it's angering yeah no that was
that was very angrying
um but now it's still the CW so power to
them and you know what we used to watch
a lot
Reba we watched Reba and what was that
other show with Joanna Garcia
Reba not Reba the one that she started
she privileged privileged yeah but that
was later in life
no but still in the same room no like
those no not in the same room privilege
really like privilege was on the CW
are you sure okay I'm pretty sure
because I rewatched it recently on CW
seed even though I do think what was
iconic
I know what else did we watch as kids I
feel like we watched Friends
unfortunately because we didn't ABC
family we watched before it was freeform
do you remember that you watch that show
maybe it's me uh-huh uh-huh
yeah yeah yeah
when I go to sleep tonight I'll be
thinking about all the things that I
wish that I would have said like I
remember we used to watch this and I
remember when we used to watch that but
uh we watched like Nick at night yeah we
watched Nanny we watched all of those
things yeah we watched whatever was the
WB was serving up totally totally yeah
no it was those first 11 channels like
ABC CBS NBC we didn't really like watch
a lot of like things like we weren't
watching NBC I could tell you that no
because that's where like American Idol
that was on what at the time oh true
yeah I remember when Kelly Clarkson and
Justin Guarini faced off we were in said
same room
do you remember that's a guy I have that
core memory
I remember when um
I think it was like Taylor Hicks this
season
no memory of that no memory of that but
Kelly Clarkson very I have a very
definitive memory of winning
that they were all together watching and
the way that like we were screaming and
jumping for joy we were team Kelly
um uh by a million miles 100 always have
been it's in our room always have
literally nothing's changed nothing
nothing
okay well our next story is actually
some reality TV news that I'd love to
get your thoughts about because this
weekend was the White House
correspondence dinner and fans are
confused over Lala Ken Ari automatics
and Lisa Vanderpump's appearance at the
dinner
so Bravo fans were stunned to see Lala
Ariana and Lisa at the 2023 White House
Correspondents dinner Saturday night the
trio of reality stars looked ethereal on
the red carpet at the DC Hilton Hotel
following the highly publicized
scandival which we know I'm sure you're
familiar with the scandal of all I sure
am familiar
so these three from the show went to the
White House correspondence center with
the LA Times
question mark they did I thought that
they went with I saw them in a picture
with Lindy yaccarino who's the
chairwoman of NBC Universal and my
friend Shelly's Alice and I thought for
sure that Linda brought from
stars or from the night before because
the night before there was like a big
party in town that they also went to I
think it was like CAA or one of the
talent agencies like had a a party oh I
don't know I don't know I gotta go back
and look LA Times So Random so random
and okay so maybe the LA Times is like
thirsting a little bit like because they
the the Publications like get tables for
this big event and like you can give
away tickets so you give it to like you
could give it to someone influential or
something you want to sit with or
someone that's going to create Buzz for
your right
for your publication so they chose like
three Vanderpump people but I think that
the choice of the three is also
interesting I was talking about it with
Claudia like of course Ariana is the
belle of the ball these days and like
she is the first invite but I was
surprised that Lala was there like I
feel like maybe Katie could have gone
and then like Lisa's kind of random too
but I mean I'm here for it I hope they
had an amazing time they looked gorgeous
truly beautiful
all three of them really they really
looked
um dress perfectly like for the affair
you know yeah but I'm just so confused
as to why who what where when why how
they were there I'm confused too I
wonder like I don't know the nuances of
the friendships on Vanderpump Rules like
our Lala and Ariana cool they're cool
everybody's cool now all the girls are
cool so maybe she asked to bring her I
feel like your point about Ariana being
the belle of the ball makes a lot of
sense like maybe Ariana got two tickets
and she gave them to Lisa and Lala I
don't know yeah
yeah I need to know more like and you
know what they all have podcasts so um
hasn't like really been around that much
in a while like I I don't see her like
go to events and do things really well
she kind of just does her own stuff like
she does Vanderpump Rules and then she
opens up her restaurants and like she
kind of just like feeds her own
ecosystem which is like a nice level to
be at a hundred percent yeah no that's
why I'm more so surprised to see her
because I'm like I feel like I haven't
seen you in a while you know yeah at
least for me like she's like just like
not on my radar even though like the
show's Vanderpump Rules obviously I just
and I know she's in the show but like I
don't know I just feel like the rest of
them Housewives you always just see in
different instances
yeah but she's not a housewife anymore
did you know that I know yes I heard
that she's not in a housewife anymore I
actually muted myself to choke because I
don't we remember professionals at this
because like I don't know the mouth is
dry
you're welcome to take a sip of water
okay I'm gonna take I'm going to take
you off on method you take your water
and I'm gonna let you know what our next
story is because it is some programming
news Jada Pinkett Smith's red table talk
has been among the shows canceled as
Facebook watch is shut down by meta so
red table talk is closing its doors for
now the popular talk show co-hosted by
Jada Pinkett Smith her mother and her
daughter has been canceled as its
Network Facebook watch is shut down by
meta people confirms deadline was the
first to report the news that Facebook
watches original programming Endeavors
were ending with none of it shows
returning for tomorrow for more seasons
it added that red table talk was being
shopped around to other interested
networks variety reported that it's a
cost cutting measure so this story is
pretty twofold like one Facebook watch
is gone like we don't have to
accidentally click that tab on our
phones anymore that's like really joyous
um and two that means red table talk no
longer has a home there but I do feel
like it could get picked up by someone
else but for now it's kaput I think so
too and I think you know honestly I
didn't even realize that red table talk
was a part of Facebook watch meta watch
whatever like I think honestly the the
point of this story is like a million
fold number one Facebook has to like
stop trying to be all things to all
people you know like they want to be
like a studio like a Netflix creating
original programming and they're gonna
bring us to the metaverse and here they
have Instagram and WhatsApp and a VR set
with oculus and it's just like chill you
know so to some extent I don't I don't
want to say that I'm like I'm glad that
Facebook watch didn't work out but it's
like I understand like they're just you
can't be all things to all people it's
too [__] much number one yeah maybe
let's say you can take igtv with them
yeah I think that's gone I don't even
know
um that's embarrassing for Instagram to
be honest with you but
um the second point is yeah I would say
that if anything like red table talk is
probably the only program on Facebook
watches anybody was specifically tuning
into Facebook watch to watch other than
their random ass other programming that
they were shoving down our throats I
don't know like in this article I never
heard of these shows but they sound like
real shows peace of mind with Taraji P
Henson the Beavers on Watch and
Elizabeth Olsen's drama series sorry for
your loss
with Jessica Biel no I've never heard of
them but like they sound like real shows
they sound like real shows but then like
also how we never heard of them you know
yeah it was one Facebook watch thing it
was like Tom versus time about Tom Brady
that one I watched but that was
legitimately like five or six years ago
like they've just been out this too long
and haven't cracked the code so like
sayonara
yeah and it's just you know the Facebook
users Behavior it's just not where we
want to watch our TV like I've said so
many times before I don't need one app
to do everything for me like I like
having my phone where I do this and my
TV where I do that and my computer where
I do this and these different apps like
I don't need it all in-house yeah no I
totally agree with that and I think but
don't tell Mark Zuckerberg no red table
talk is interesting because they have
interesting guests right like yeah it's
all guest dependent like I think of
course
yeah of course so
um I don't know like maybe they should
you know shop it around TNN could take
the audio format LOL no I think that I
think they'll get picked up and I think
that they should get picked up like it's
a good concept they have amazing like
guest Outreach and have good
conversations with people it gets tons
of buzz it gets more Buzz than cable
news shows or cable talk shows so
someone should snag it yeah but you know
what it makes me think about like all
those quibby shows that like had yes too
and never got picked up anywhere but
like they didn't really have buzz and
they also like weren't whole shows no I
know the IP on any of them didn't appear
anywhere else
it's been like a year and a half since
quibby went under
yeah it's been like three years but um
yeah it was 2020. wow again time I have
absolutely no concept of but yeah I
think about quibby often actually do you
yes sometimes but all I would say about
red table talking why it's different
it's because it's like an established
show and it's long form like they
wouldn't have to change anything yeah
they wouldn't have to like even like get
new audience members it's just like copy
and paste whereas with quibby it was
like they were ideas
yeah yeah no I definitely agree with
that but they just had invested in so
much that it's like I know you would
think yes but I agree with you I I think
that you will be reporting on rev table
talk Landing somewhere in the next few
weeks or months for sure as it should
um and I think honestly the fact that
they were at Facebook watch I'm glad
Facebook watch shut down so that red
table talk could go somewhere else
there I said yeah yeah and I'm glad like
like Facebook watch is winding down for
sure for sure there's just like that was
unnecessary and also like it's been too
long you know like sometimes I
appreciate when companies try things and
then like after a year or two if it
doesn't work like great like
fold in that what is it like put in the
towel fold in there throw it in the
towel throw in the towel yeah throw in
the towel Facebook
what do you think this means for the
industry since you are like a media
Queen well I think that there's so much
going on in the media space right now
with all of these you know big networks
and cable channels like launching their
own streaming services and I think at
some point there has to be some sort of
consolidation you know like you have
Amazon Prime you have Netflix you have
Hulu HBO Max and then you have NBC with
peacock and Paramount plus like there's
just so much and you know people don't
want to spend you know hundreds of
dollars across 15 different services to
access content so like I think you will
continue to see a Media consolidation
like I think you know what Hulu Disney
ESPN are trying to do right now or
they're kind of like all together and
then there's going to be opportunities
for cross-sharing in terms of content
like I think we'll be seeing a little
bit more of that but ultimately at the
end of the day whoever produces good
content that gets people to watch like
is going to be the winner and I think
right now with the way that Netflix does
it and how they can drive so much like
fomo around shows that they create and
then they have it be trending and
everybody's talking about it and you
have to watch it it's like you're gonna
have to have Netflix to be able to
access that so I think the media Space
is really interesting right now I think
it's a great time for Content because
people are just like all consumed but
the one thing I will say that I'm really
actually not liking is how like they
created a monster in us to binging yeah
and now they're like Episode by episode
and to be honest with you I'm just
absolutely not here for it like I think
it's so wrong you can't like
dramatically change a consumer behavior
and then just be like nope like not okay
no when Claudia and I also say it's like
okay one there they went from binging to
being like episodic to like a lot of
these new platforms have [__]
commercials and three they're all
consolidating like into one sort of
platform it's cable yeah it's turning in
into cable a hundred percent and you're
paying 150 bucks like you would when you
know if you live in New York and you
have spectrum and you have a thousand
jobs
the key is not to have cable because
Zach and I don't have cable as you guys
know we're cord cutters and we have
every between YouTube TV and then we pay
for whatever streamers we want yeah our
bill is so much less than cable yeah the
only reason why I have some basic cable
is because Shapiro needs it for sports
which you guys get on YouTube uh right
yeah no I and like I need cable access
like I like to watch like
yeah things live you know Grammys or
whatever
um but YouTube TV has all of that love
that for you love it you should you know
you're the face of YouTube TV at least
in my mind I've had a pleasure you've
had it for so long actually yeah yeah
since like since we got engaged so 2018
yeah yeah it's been Pleasant I would
recommend to a friend and that's a good
example of like YouTube like went into
the TV space and it's positive and they
continued to do it if after two years it
was a sham like they should have shut it
down but they didn't but it's also it's
weird that that it's YouTube Owned like
it has nothing to do with YouTube no I
know but it's more so just like the
facilitation of video distribution which
YouTube is the biggest dub in the world
yeah but no it's it's like weird and
also like you can't like watch YouTube
videos in the YouTube TV app you have to
get the separate YouTube app yeah yeah
which never really like made a ton of
sense yeah no I agree with that it's
it's like confusing they look the same
but okay go off YouTube
today's episode is also brought to you
by Skylight frames you guys if you need
the perfect gift for Mother's Day
Father's Day or any loved one birthday
holiday anything Skylight frames is
always the perfect gift idea we get so
many questions what was that code for
the frame again and listen up because we
have a great code for you guys today and
this is a great product so Skylight is a
digital photo frame and it's a wonderful
meaningful gift that will give you a
great way to stay in touch with those
that you love it's perfect for a mother
or Father's Day gift it's simple and fun
to use even if you're not tech savvy
especially if you're not tech savvy
there's no app or subscription required
to send photos anytime from anywhere so
basically you buy the Skylight frame for
someone it's so pretty and so cute and
it matches your beautiful home decor and
then the person who bought it for you is
able to send photos digitally to the
frame and you know you could change it
up every single day if you wanted to
Fresh photos of your pet you know
Claudia loves to send pictures of Theo I
love to send her pictures of my family
we have Skylight frames in our homes and
it's a great extra way for us to stay in
touch as if we don't stay in touch
enough already but it's just a really
cute way to update people with your life
and stay connected at all times so we
have a great code now as a special offer
in time for Mother's Day and for others
and Father's day you'll get 10 off
that's up to 30 off your frame when you
go to skylightframe.com toast that's
right to get 10 off up to 30 off your
purchase of a skylight frame just go to
skylightframe.com toast that's
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash
toast you guys it's the perfect gift and
and you cannot go wrong today's episode
is also brought to you by ZocDoc because
ZocDoc is the platform that you have
been looking for if you need any sort of
doctor or expert for me having moved
like you have to find all new people and
honestly I didn't realize how many
people I needed to find and how
difficult that would be especially if
you don't have an existing
Network already it's easy to go on a
social media Rabbit Hole like Googling
symptoms and self-prescribing when what
you actually need to do is go on ZocDoc
so no more Dr roulette or scouring the
internet for questionable reviews with
ZocDoc you have a trusted guide to
connect you to your favorite doctor you
haven't met yet millions of people use
zocdoc's free app to find and book a
doctor in their neighborhood who is a
patient reviewed doctor and fits their
needs and schedule just right so you can
select through a bevy of doctors you can
sort by your insurance provider then you
can find the right doctor for you you
can read reviews you can schedule
through ZocDoc whatever time works best
for you they make it so easy and really
just a
such a great modern convenience honestly
go to zocdoc.com toast and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours even so go to
zocdoc.com toast that
zocdoc.com toast and find the right DOC
for you okay our next story is actually
some really crazy news I know that you
watch cheers season one so you're
familiar with all these players but
cheer star Monica aldama the coach has
been sued for allegedly covering up
sexual assault Monica aldama who starred
in popular Netflix docu-series cheer
allegedly told a former student to keep
quiet about being sexually assaulted
according to court documents obtained by
Page Six cheerleader Maddie Lane claims
that she was sexually assaulted
assaulted by a teammate during her first
semester at Navarro she claims that the
alleged assault occurred in 2021 after
her then roommate invited a group of
guys over to their dorm after a night of
partying
she said that she told Coach Monica what
allegedly happened and claims the coach
told her quote let's not make this a big
deal I want the best for you and I will
help you cheer wherever you want when
she quit the team a week later Monica
reportedly told her to keep quiet if she
wanted to continue her collegiate career
in cheerleading
uh she also claims that some of that one
of the veteran cheerleaders told her the
same thing saying quote we don't tell
anyone we just keep it to ourselves uh
she now is on a cheer team at the
University of Texas and claimed that her
dream of cheering um on the nationally
ranked team was squashed after Navarro
coaches and former teammates blackballed
her from other programs for coming
forward about the alleged assault
well
um one I just think that's terrible but
also the one thing about cheer that was
so crazy is that there was this guy did
you watch cheer by the way yeah yeah
okay so in the first season like Jerry
was like yeah and then Jerry so there is
something no bueno in the water over
there in Navarro and like it's not okay
well I think it was cheer the most
recent season I don't know if it was two
or three and it was like I think it must
have been two it was like kind of
postcovid but still it was a little
Masky and they were talking about like
the Jerry stuff and how there's kind of
like a cheer curse it feels like like
ever since the first season like just
it's not been positive for a lot of
people like I think Monica really
strugged with a lot of stuff she went on
Dancing With the Stars and she was just
like stressed the hell out and
I don't know it was like just becoming
like a seen this cheer curse and that's
what this story just like Echoes to me
it's just like maybe the spotlight of
the show just brought to light all of
these things that were always there but
you know we wouldn't have that sort of
attention if not for the show and I
guess that's a curse but
it's really crazy and this is really
disappointing if true because Monica was
like America you know she's a like
everyone fell in love with Monica and
her coaching abilities but also like her
ability to just really be there for the
cheer cheers and be like a a motherly
figure and this is just this would be
completely out of line with what we
thought we knew her character to be
totally yeah no I couldn't agree more
and I think yeah it's interesting I
hadn't heard about the cheer curse but I
do think like that's such a big thing
with reality TV right it's like you just
don't know what is gonna unravel and I
think
um honestly good for this girl for
regardless of the fact that it's
horrendous that she got blackballed from
other programs like I would say she's
probably such a Beacon of Hope for so
many people that are reading the story
and it's like coming forward even if you
put everything that you care about at
risk to like help other people honestly
good for her Maddie we'll keep you
posted on this story yeah keep me posted
on the story actually I had him that was
just really surprising very surprising
um but yeah there's that's what I was
saying earlier is like everything that
you hear now about cheer which I think
is your point in the cheer curse is like
so vile
yeah yeah
you know flips and tricks and fun stuff
not do a flip yeah
I think there's another season happening
oh so maybe this will be a part of it I
actually probably don't think so oh
they'll definitely sweep it under the
rug that seems to be their specialty
yeah I I don't know but it's just it's
not good over at Navarro no it's not
Navarro is a college sometimes like yeah
like when I was watching cheer I like
Got High School Vibes the kids are so if
they feel like they're so young
well that's just I think our age College
I know I know it's it's me it's me I
know you're showing your age I am I'm
old
are you ready for our fifth and final
story real we're already at five
yeah that's insane I thought we were at
four I don't even like again just joggy
the time is fine time flies when you're
having fun with your sis I am I'm having
so much fun
it's actually the fifth and final story
is some cute news for the kids and also
some major box office news because Super
Mario Brothers the movie officially
smashed one billion dollars globally wow
the Super Mario Brothers movie is
officially the first film of the year to
cross the coveted one billion dollar
Milestone at the global box office as of
Sunday after 26 days of release the
animated video game adaptation from
Universal illumination and Nintendo has
grossed 400 million 490 million dollars
in North America and 532 million
internationally it's only the fifth
movie of pandemic times to join the
billion dollar Club including Spider-Man
Top Gun Jurassic world dominion and
Avatar
wow well one good for Super Mario
um two the pandemic times like the
post-pandemic movie times are so weird
like I have not been to a movie theater
in legitimately four years and like I
don't know when I'm gonna go back like
it's like it used to be so on my radar
in terms of like things that I would do
I think one just obviously having kids
now that are not like age-appropriate to
go to the theater just yet is probably
one big reason for it but two like damn
the way that like the theater suffered
during the pandemic like it the way that
movies come out now like that whole
industry is like so flipped on its head
it's like it's wild
yeah I think it changed a lot of things
also we now see like movies go to
theaters and then they are they're
available on demand really quickly which
is pretty nice for the consumers and I
think a lot of people say you know like
movie theater industry is just not what
it was but then like a movie like this
comes out and it breaks these records in
26 days and it's like oh well maybe the
other movies are just like
kind of shitty and nobody wants to see
them because when people want to go see
a movie they clearly go and see it by
the way I agree with that and I think
the other thing too is to your point
earlier about being a cord cutter I feel
like most of the studios only really
like advertise their movies and their
trailers on like cable TV because like I
don't see any movie trailers anymore now
that I like don't watch you know cable
TV so like I don't even ever know like
what's coming out like I heard about it
more so this movie I heard about
I see them like on social media like on
Instagram you know like the Barbie
trailer I didn't see it yeah Barbie but
okay like but that's what I'm saying
like Barbie air Super Mario like I saw
those ones but like I cannot tell you
other than those three movies what else
has been in theaters in the last two
months
of like the Oscar contenders I had
literally not heard of one Oscar movie
I guess I just heard of them well I mean
I also like do this job yeah no it's
your job but I'm just saying like me a
plebe a regular consumer like I don't
watch like cable TV and I do not see
trailers and I do not know what movies
are in theaters and then I only know
because then like when I turn my TV on
it's like the new releases come up if
like I'm on Apple or like whatever and
then I can see ticket to Paradise with
Julia Roberts and George Clooney you
know yeah did you watch that I did well
how was it um it wasn't that good
um it was really bad
I kind of
um like like would you recommend it like
Zach and I watched last night murder
mystery two oh my God no bueno oh I
didn't hate it like it was like just the
perfect dumb thing it's a perfect dumb
thing yeah it's dumb I totally agree
um I would probably have recommended
that more than I would have remember
recommended ticket to Paradise the other
one I watched was the shotgun wedding
JLo
the one that I think Army Hammer was
supposed to yeah
that was one of the worst movies I've
ever seen oh T do you see her movie
marry me
um I did that which one was worse
was Marry Me the one with Owen Wilson
yes okay so so bad it was bad but I
watched that one on a plane and I still
didn't watch movies on the plane like
you get this like heightened emotional
like I I don't know like that one did
you cry no I didn't cry but I just like
it was feel good like I was into it you
know this one Jackie was like the the
and like side effects like the action
was so completely unrealistic like it
was horrendous like it was actually the
worst movie I've ever seen in my life
ticket to Paradise I feel like because
they're both like weddings on an island
Vibe I'm getting them confused in my
mind almost but uh
it just like I can't say anything
positive about that one but the shotgun
wedding one literally is should go down
in history as the worst movie I've ever
seen since today's episode has so many
nostalgic memories between Liv and I it
is only fitting that today's episode the
rest of the episode is brought to you by
Legacy box which is a sponsor that we
absolutely love and adore here at the
toast because we love reliving the past
and all of our wonderful memories over
the years so if you guys don't know what
Legacy box is it is the idea that you
wish that you thought of but someone
else did so it's all good basically with
Legacy box you send in your box they
send you an empty box you send in your
legacy box filled with old VHS tapes
camcorder tapes and pictures their team
professionally digitizes everything by
hand right here in the USA you'll get it
back on a thumb drive or the cloud along
with your Originals it's so simple it's
like magic so if you have you know a
whole box or a whole storage unit full
of old videos and pictures that you just
want to digitize Legacy box does that
for you and they make it so easy we have
loved reliving childhood memories with
Legacy box I've defining instances of
Olivia being obsessed with the
Backstreet Boys so that I can prove to
her that for a brief moment in time she
was you know a Brian girlie and she has
come to
have to accept that fact because I've
given her Rock Solid proof thanks to
Legacy box also with Mother's Day
quickly approaching it's a great gift
for the whole family it really is an
amazing gift idea it's so thoughtful and
you know it's also pretty easy so it's a
win-win for a limited time go to
legacybox.com toast for their best
Mother's Day sale ever buy today to take
advantage of 60 off Legacy box send it
in when you're ready go to legacybox.com
toast and be the hero of your family
bringing back all of these wonderful
memories to the four Claudia and I had
this conversation like a few months ago
and it was pretty controversial point
that I raised but like George Clooney is
like kind of like not a serious actor
no no I I feel like he used to be and
he's not anymore
yeah like now I feel like he doesn't act
as much but then like he does and he
does that like cheesy rom-coms yeah yeah
yeah like he does like really corny
stuff like he's kind of super important
yeah but then he did that other movie
with like Anna Kendrick like up in the
air and all the oceans movies like he
used to do legitimate films and now I
agree with your point like it's no no
bueno yeah yeah yeah for sure so do you
think that you'll be taking Kayla to see
Super Mario Brothers
no but I'm excited for it to come out on
demand and for me to watch it I just
don't think she can sit in the theater
for like that oh yeah no sorry not take
then you don't have to take her to see
but like do you think that you would
have her watch that since apparently the
kids are loving it
um I would be happy to turn it on but
the thing about Kayla is like when she
sets her sights on something like she
doesn't come out of that hole for a
while so like we're so knee-deep in High
School Musical right now thanks to
Claudia that like but you know that
Claudia like Claudia voice did that on
her like if you want her to be obsessed
with something like I feel like you
could kind of no it has to there's
certain things that would make her
criteria right criteria music is the
number one so like Super Mario Brothers
has that song I know but is it a musical
jacket can we listen to the playlist in
the car like that is criteria numeral
okay okay yeah but like I love Super
Mario like we used to play that as kids
this is becoming such a nostalgic
episode it is I know it is I know Live
and Let Live is the leading title but it
might be like
it might have to be something with
Nostalgia nobody but you know exactly
what I'm talking about like we used to
have Super Mario on our computers and we
used to play yeah we were in video game
girlies but that was the one and only
game that was the one that we liked yeah
and snood
snood Icy Tower Icy Tower yeah yeah yeah
okay so we played a few games but not
video games computers no no computer
games because we were like academics
no because in between you know writing
papers we would just do a little
computer game no we were like what was
that website what was that website Aqua
something
that had all the games
oh I don't know let's say that had all
the games
I don't know Jackie I don't know you're
better you you and your memory come on
it'll come to me okay cool
we used to play a lot of games
yeah because like we were like the
generation like right where like
computers in terms of like everyday life
like obviously like that AOL aim
generation you know and like using your
computer for like homework and school
work was like the norm right at the cusp
of like when we were going to high
school and stuff yeah yeah
all very cool well Olivia thank you for
helping us deliver the Fast Five it has
been a pleasure to catch up with you I
know the toasters are going to be so
happy to hear from you and to hear your
take on oh look at you a little turdy
Lou over there oh my God this is like is
that the turdy Lou way she just breaks
out in song
so you've listened to zero episodes no
no I know but I feel like yeah yeah I
guess you know do you know what I mean
like if you say a word does she like
sing from there are a few tropes that we
have like when I say thank you like
she'll read the ads and I say thank you
and she goes it's a pleasure oh oh I
didn't realize okay cool yeah so you're
just really filling in on all fronts for
trying today big shoes to fill over here
big the biggest biggest episode
no I know we should actually like say
whatever you want no I was just gonna
say like let's leave this Easter egg
yeah and see if she's like oh yeah you
know I did listen or there's a chance
she would listen because she's going on
a plane
um truth truth truth but I don't see it
for her I really don't I think she'll
she's enjoying her day off as she should
because she's been holding it down the
last few weeks and we are immensely
grateful for turdy Lou but I will be
back with her tomorrow on the show and
tonight
Monday night is the Met Gala and so
tomorrow's episode is going to be so fun
I'm really excited to see what everyone
brings I hope everyone brings their a
game I'm already seeing like so many
like teaser stuff because the theme is
Carl Carl which is like a really good
theme like Rihanna stepped out like in
the Chanel glasses and it's giving you
know and like I heard no Kardashians no
they're going Kim Kim posted she's going
people just love to like lie on their
names yeah what is up with that weird
yes they're definitely like all going I
mean I don't know about Courtney and
Chloe
TBD just because I don't know if they
enjoyed it last time like I don't know
that they would want to go again enough
right like I know Chloe I just watched
the episode from last season Chloe had
like immense horrible anxiety like she
doesn't like red carpets like I don't
think it was fun for her
that makes sense so we'll see and if
they do go to all of them I really hope
one designer takes them all and dresses
them cohesively that's my that's my Met
Gala wish I wish for you ooh um
I don't know I don't really have a
mecheloish I just hope that like that's
normal that's normal no
um I just hope we have like some you
know some good luck some interesting
Peeps and I will be like following along
adjacently you know yeah like I'm not
gonna be sitting in front of the stream
like that's just not my vibe no I never
watch the stream but Claudia likes to
watch it
no I definitely want I want to be wowed
you know like I want to see some cool
people wear some beautiful things and I
I think the theme sometimes the theme is
like too outrageous for me to fully
understand like what people are doing
and like you can't really mess this
theme up yeah I think it's gonna be it
would be disrespectful to mess this
thing oh yeah you know Carl would be
vomiting if you [__] vomiting yeah
yeah for sure for sure for sure so no I
think it's gonna be fun and that's
always a fun pop culture
touch point so have you ever seen a
documentary the first Monday of May I
think I did I think I watched it on a
plane yeah
it was good very interesting but no what
was the other documentary that they did
about the September issue was it called
the September issue yeah but there's
also another documentary that's like
seven days or something like that where
it's like seven days before like the
biggest events in the world I think that
Miguel is one of them Kentucky Derby uh
I didn't watch that cool
yeah I think so I think I watched some
of them I definitely watched the
Kentucky Derby one I thought it was
really interesting
that's cool yeah I'm into like sports
documentaries too I find them
fascinating you such a cool chill girl I
mean the mantai Teo one was the best so
come on yeah totally well Liv where can
everyone keep up with you and your
life
um at Olivia ashrae I feel like my
growth has been stagnant so um if you're
feeling like throwing the followers
yeah yeah yeah let's try for a bump you
know might as well
um but yeah you can keep up with me
there where I just like post my Suburban
life and my recipes
um I did a little bit of a Costco haul
this weekend you know just the things
that an average girly does because
that's me an average girly
we love it thank you so much for joining
us we will see you next time and
toasters I shall see you tomorrow
goodbye ciao
you know how we ended we say love you
bye obviously love ya bye bye